pourquoi on s'engueule je sais pas c'est
n'importe quoi n'importe nawak belmont
furax contre moi parfois je croyais que
tu es j'ai souvent envie de têtu et
comment tu ferais je sais pas avec du
poison je crois je mettrais du poison
dans tes petits gâteaux ce que tu fais
semblant de pas manger et j'en mettrais
juste assez pour te vider tout doucement
des forces j'adore j'aurais vraiment
heureuse les derniers mois oui oui parce
que tu serais tout faibles tout gentil
et je serai à ton chevet et en même
temps je serai en 38 20 c'est ce que
j'aime chez nous que tu arrive toujours
à surprendre je me serais attendu à ce
que tu débarrasse de moi d'un coup en
faisant prendre du poisson mais jamais à
ce que tu fasses durer le plaisir des
semaines
et toi tu as déjà pensé à me tais c'est
vrai je te jure notamment tu ferais
ouailles aux abois voix hier à bois
broyé à pois ouais ouais mais j'essaie
de talus fargo ouais